gildas au tour de france vous le suivez
mais vous ne vivez pas vous suivez parce
que vous aimez
oui enfin je le suis depuis toujours
mieux quand j'étais pensionnaire à
rennes ya très très longtemps c'était la
bagarre robic bobet c'était deux bretons
et vous pouvez pas savoir où se battait
en cours de récréation il y avait des
robic qui était la bretagne sud chez moi
et puis il y avait les bugs et la
bretagne nord mais c'était une passion
cinglé mais je trouve aujourd'hui que
peu importe pour les dames qu'elles
aiment ou n'aiment pas le vélo qu'ils y
connaissent quelques je crois que c'est
passé à ce même endroit sur le bord de
la route à savoir parce que c'est une
histoire d'hommes en fait c'est typique
sont cinglés il faut vraiment faire une
étape de montagne avait regardé
descendre à cent à l'heure avec les
voitures on n'arrive pas y aller espace
comme l'aimé des zombies c'est je trouve
celle enregistrée dans les pyrénées ou
dans les alpes
je ne sais pas pour faire plaisir je
serrais les pyrénées alors il y ait une
autre avis radio luxembourg le journal
de 20 heures c'était je crois en 69
c'est avec etienne mougeotte ensuite il
ya eu la tête et paie des groupes et des
couilles c'est vrai et ensuite il ya eu
la tête et les jambes il ya eu en europe
numéro on va aller vite parce que
autrement là à la carrière sur la chasse
aux trésors la souris la chance d'élever
la première est une émission qui
reprises d'ailleurs se feront en dessous
de notre titre aujourd'hui
il y aujourd'hui nulle part ailleurs
alors faut-il avoir tout fait dans une
vie d'homme de télévision non pas du
tout je pense que vous êtes vous en avez
fait largement autant vous en avez sauté
certaines vous avez pris des principales
mais si je prenais les votes en a pour
trois jours oui mais je viens
aujourd'hui peut-être les gens ne se
consacrent sont beaucoup plus dans les
secteur bien particulier
je me la leçon que je retire de ce
parcours quand je le regarde comme ça la
leçon que je retire pour moi c'est que
je ne regrette pas d'avoir toujours
pensé qu'il y avait quelque chose à
prendre à côté que c'est très bien par
exemple de présenter le journal de 20h
mais là on était des hommes troncs à
l'époque pourquoi j'ai accepté de
de faire la tête et les jambes c'est que
dans la tête et les jambes je marchais
et je n'étais plus à la métro et
j'apprenais à me servir des caméras bon
je vais pas vous raconter la suite
mais c'est vrai que c'est bien
d'apprendre toutes les facettes et c'est
vrai que ça me permet aujourd'hui de
faire nulle part ailleurs où il ya
autant de chaudes choi de spectacle que
de peu d'informations alors je disais
nulle part ailleurs il y à un orchestre
il ya un public il y à du clinquant il y
à des paillettes il ya une véritable
réussite
et puis la facilité d'être sur canal+ ça
va canal+ qui vous permet à chivu qui
autorise toute cette liberté d'un mot
seulement tout le clinquant les
paillettes et tourne à un superbe studio
c'est vrai il ya eu quelques critiques
dessus en disant mais ils se prennent
pour des gosses de riches n'est pas vrai
du tout il faut pas oublier qu'on fait
1h45 et c'est tous les jours donc le
studio est largement rentabilisé donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu y mettre même
un orchestre alors comment se fait-il
que vous ayez envie de changer car à la
rentrée vous allez transformer toutes
les donnes a pas plus que d'habitude
puisque débit non j'ai toujours changer
comme ça j'étais à la création avec
alain de greef c'était dans 87 on a
tenté cette fois-là l'arrivée des nuls
qui il a d'abord fallu donner un nom
parce qu'il n'est même pas de nom puis
ensuite l'année d'après il ya eu la
troupe d'antoine karl zéro s'appelait
pea kg puis l'année d'après cet été
antoine proprement dits se déguise en
bref tous les ans on change on évolue en
fait de ces guignols
les guignols oui vous savez bien qu'ils
sont d'abord appelé les arènes de l'info
donc même à l'intérieur de chaque
tranche ça évolue la grande nouveauté
c'est que alors que cette année on avait
fait une heure quarante-cinq je crois
qu'on va passer à 1h50 l'an prochain
mais qu'on va donner la première
demi-heure à bonaldi qui fera une forme
très différente de nulle part ailleurs
de saidal et on va essayer une autre
formule au tour de jerome avec des
chroniqueurs et puis on reprendra la
formule plus resserrée mais sur une
heure vingt quand même du nil par
ailleurs traditionnel craignent vous
craignez le 19 20 heures présenté par
michel drucker ou
le jeu où la grande série qui va venir
sur tf1 dans le même espace que le vôtre
non non je rail à rien je crains pas
parce que le plaisir c'est la
concurrence de même c'est de regarder
les autres c'est on est quand même été
très fier du parieur le jour on a vu de
chavannes arrivée sur le même créneau
on s'est dit quand même on n'avait pas
tout à fait tort
[Musique]